[Evans] Let's test our new hash function, see if it does better than the bad string hash function
we defined earlier.
We're going to use the same testhashfunction we defined before
that takes the function as input so we can pass in either the original bad string hash function
or the new hashstring function that we hope will work better,
a list of keys, and the size, computing the hash value for each key
and records how many end up in each position.
So let's try that again.
We'll use the same example we had before, using the words from Sherlock Holmes.
We'll initialize words as all the words in the page
that is The Adventures of Sherlock Holmes that we load from the Web.
First we'll try this again with the old hash function, the bad string hash,
and obtain the counts.
Let's print those out. Remember what those look like.
It's a pretty bad distribution, as we saw before,
ranging from 725 all the way up to over 2000 in 1 bucket.
Now let's try it with the new hash function.
Instead of badhashstring, we'll pass in plain hashstring.
We're using the same words, the same number of buckets,
and we'll see the distribution now.
It looks a lot better.
There's no values under 1000 now.
There's no values over-- The highest one would be 1363 in the first bucket.
So let's look at that graphically.
Here's what we had before with the badhashstring function.
We can see the size of the buckets varies a great deal
and we have the red and blue bars showing some that are too popular,
some that are not popular enough.
With the new hash function we have much less variance.
Still not perfect. We'd like to have all the bars really be as close to the same as possible.
But it's really close. So this is working pretty well.
The other thing we can try is having more buckets. Let's try this.
Now we're doing the same thing but this time with 100 buckets instead of 12 buckets.
We can print that out.
And so we see the results when we have 100 buckets are pretty good
but certainly not perfect.
We have buckets as small as this one that has 104
and as large as this one that has 197, so almost twice the size of the smallest bucket.
It's certainly a hard problem to build a better hash function.
People put a lot of effort into building good hash functions.
As your tables get larger, it's very important to have the hash function be efficient.
Our hashstring function is not that great because it does take a long time to execute.
If the string gets longer, we have to go through that loop once for each character.
So there are better hash functions available.
We're not going to look at those in more detail now,
but there will be some links on the website to documents
about more interesting hash functions.
This is going to work well enough for us, though.
So before we go on to actually implementing in the hash table
I'm going to have 1 quiz to make sure that you understand
why this is so much better than the original index.